[Music]
[Applause]
Seth Greenberg of the mothership joining
us on the program is fritzy wanted me to
make sure I pointed out Seth is a member
of the Jewish Sports Hall of Fame and
went in there in 2012. uh good yantiff
machinachas and uh Passover coming up
here Seth so uh thanks for joining us
my pleasure good to see you I hope
you're feeling well and uh man I'll tell
you one thing it's been interesting last
three weeks with the NCAA tournament
wait wait what do you get for going into
the Jewish Hall of Fame
uh you get a lot yeah you go to Dick's
Hills you get a nice little uh little
trophy your mom has you know feels good
about you for a while until she does it
yeah and it's one of the you know and
it's one of the few hall of fames you go
in and they don't ask you for your check
after you you go in okay
uh if I would have said this is how
basketball is going to end in April
Connecticut winning and what we saw in
the women's game with Iowa and LSU what
would be more surprising with the
reaction and surprises that we had
I would probably man that is tough I
would say Connecticut because they were
they were unranked coming into the
season I'm a Connecticut lost at New
Mexico state in the opening around the
NCAA tournament a year ago they brought
it they lost their backcourt they
brought in uh uh Tristan Newton uh who
was a two guard or they moved the point
guard now look they had good pieces but
they hadn't come together they had a red
shirt and Alex Caravan who hadn't played
a minute of basically division one
college basketball yet and he had a huge
impact on his team they relying on a
freshman coming off the bench with Don
McLean so I would say that it would
probably be
Connecticut uh their Journey has been
phenomenal and uh to move back to the
Big East was the vehicle but the driver
that bus
Danny Hurley that dude is he's the real
deal
if I said that you could recruit players
or you could do transfer portal if you
were still coaching so you could get
high school players or you go transfer
what would you use
I'd find a balance I would use the
transfer portal to fill in basically
spots where we needed help they lost our
backcourt they needed a guard they went
there they also recruited Donovan
Klingon who was going to be the best
post player in college basketball next
year so I think you've got to find a
balance look the Blue Bloods can always
recruit high school players because
they're only recruiting the very best
high school players here's the problem
it's those other guys that they're
recruiting high school players that
maybe not already that have to take time
to to understand how to play hard how to
play with other good players the problem
is the lack of patience for those guys
those guys go to a place and you know
what there's a good chance they're going
to lead because the static around all of
these young players that is so great
that if they don't get what they want
when they want it they they feel like
the best thing is to move on and that's
where I I think Connecticut has really
done a good job they've gotten some high
school guys developed those guys they've
bought in uh and he's he didn't just
acquire Talent
what he's done is he's built a team the
piece is fit they Embrace roles uh they
don't do what they can't do you know I
heard you talking a little earlier about
uh the conversation with the
non-conference they lost six of eight
well first of all Danny had covet he
missed a bunch of practices you get into
League Play there are no surprises there
are no surprises League Play people know
what they're going to give what they're
going to take away what who they're
going to force to make plays so you're
going to lose games in League Play I
mean they lost twice to Xavier very very
good team they lost at Providence uh St
John's I think at home was a little bit
of a shocker they lost to a certain
style of team but uh watching them
practice and I go watch them practice a
whole bunch the standard they set in
practice is unbelievable the guy could
really coach the other thing you guys
were talking about earlier is
Danny really didn't miss any steps then
right look his his basketball career as
a player was maybe what everyone wanted
it to be he faced his demons he lived
with it he was an assistant coach to his
dad at St Anthony's his dad runs the
best practice I've ever seen including
watching UB Brown John Calipari Bill
self and any other person that we would
all know who they are because that is a
master teacher and Coach assistant coach
for his dad assistant coach at Rutgers
got fired head coach at St Benedict's
High School built a National High School
power
Wagner low division one 25 games this
last year Rhode Island mid major all
right back to back NCAA tournaments
advancing the tournament and then to
UConn so like he's 50 years old but he
paid his dues nothing was given to him
he took he went step by step to build uh
an understanding of what it takes to be
an elite leader an elite coach he grew
as the season went along this year so I
I'm so impressed with his growth and
what he's been able to do he's Seth
Greenberg ESPN college basketball
analyst
you start to look at what is you know
sports are it's a copycat sport you know
like the greatest show on Turf the Rams
everybody wanted to be like that
everybody wants to be like Golden State
now you start to look at college
basketball and is there a blueprint that
you think and maybe this isn't for the
Blue Bloods but the mid Majors although
I can't call UConn a mid major but the
blueprint for success in the next five
years or ten years are we witnessing
that with name image and likeness and
the transfer portal
yeah I think that I think the blueprint
is to find a balance uh but never lower
your standard uh that you know you've
got to have a foundation look we're
looking at these teams that are in the
final four year and year and year year
and year
they're veteran teams they're teams that
are invested in winning there are guys
that buy into roles I mean think about
the Villanova national championship
teams right they weren't one and done
teams they were teams that were put
together and grew think about North
Carolina's national championship teams
they had great players they had Pros but
they weren't one and done they were
experienced to think about Baylor and
that great backcourt or they were upper
class I think about this Connecticut
team so I think you got to find a
balance uh between the Player
Development
evaluating and recruiting the most
important part of recruiting is
evaluating who can play for your head
coach
uh and then filling those voids in with
the right
transfers that will buy in and take you
from a good team to a great team uh each
school is different but the top 20s the
Blue Bloods quote unquote Blue Bloods
not Connecticut's a blue blood five
national championships since 1999. think
about this during that time period
Kentucky's got one Kansas has got to
Duke's got three Carolina's got three
Connecticut's got five
so I mean the Blue Bloods are going to
be able to recruit elite players but
just acquiring talent doesn't win games
but look they've got a McDonald's
All-American coming in but you know
they've also got guys returning but look
at John Calipari and his blueprint he's
had more Talent than any coach probably
has in the last 30 years more players
drafted you know he loves to point out
they've made billions of dollars but it
doesn't work in the bigger picture of
winning championships and he's got
another unbelievable recruiting class
coming in
are we going to see the same with you
know Kentucky and and Coach Cal got a
lot of talent and they're going to be
one and done
that's why he's got a compliment into
the portal that's why he's got he's got
to get Oscars she would have come back
first and foremost which I think he
actually will end up coming back uh but
he's got a compliment DJ Wagner and that
recruit graduate that recruiting class
yeah he's got to compliment them with
Juniors and seniors that will be great
role players tutors and seniors in the
portal that will basically coach their
locker room you're only as good as your
locker like like whatever we do all
right what what you do you're always as
good as the people you surround yourself
with right so who's going to coach their
locker room who's going to teach those
young kids I like I saw something the
other day McDonald's All-American Game
they interviewed that freshman class and
they said we're going to be the freshman
class that brings Coach Cal another
championship those guys have no clue of
how hard comes basketball is they're
watching this stuff on TV down there
thinking oh yeah that's easy and you
know what this is not eybl this is not
Grassroots basketball there's a guy
coaching that other team that knows
exactly what he's going to give and what
he's going to take away he knows your
weaknesses he's going to force you to
your weaknesses you need someone to
teach those guys how to play with other
good players how to compete you can't
win I don't think with five freshmen you
need veteran maturity toughness that can
coach your locker room so that when you
go and lose six of eight like here's the
thing let me ask you a question they
lose six of eight Connecticut if they
had a team of freshmen and it's six of
eight now we're getting into February
the static around those kids
all right they think they're one and
done or are one and done they're not
thinking about winning an astral
Championship they're thinking about we
got four more weeks I got to get my
workout guy I got to get ready for my
interviews I gotta get ready for the
draft they're not thinking about winning
a championship
because there are they don't have both
feet in
it's just it's impossible the the the
economy of college basketball in
relation to the NBA draft of one and
done it's impossible if you hit a
roadblock like Connecticut hit losing
those games maybe to keep your team
together if you're just one and done
you've got to have someone in that
locker room that the focus is and a
coaching stuff that the focus is all
right where we are right now and I think
that's that's going to be the formula
you know having spoken to well Jay
Wright and Jim Boeheim the relief
like the the sense of relief that
they're not coaching anymore is really
unbelievable that you would think God
they're going to miss it uh Tom Izzo is
still doing it I mean these guys there's
a couple of dinosaurs but not many you
know they I think they're looking at
this nil and transfer portal and you
know what is going on I mean patino is
going to coach still he dies but yeah
some of these toys yeah but some of
these guys are like you know I gotta I
mean Jay Wright said yeah unbelievable
this weight lifted off my shoulders
it does damage to these coaches uh and I
wonder how many can be in there for the
Long Haul anymore
you like everything for Jay right my
daughter played volleyball Villanova so
I was around all the time is about the
culture
how can you maintain a culture in this
environment of college basketball
I mean it's really really hard
because it's so easy to walk and nil is
not nil man let's face it it's pay for
play you know we call it nil but it's
not Nia a collective is an nil it's pay
for play which is fine I like I am like
people say oh you're no I have no
problem but let's call it what it is
yeah let's not let's not label it
something it isn't I think in the next
four years we're going to have players
are going to have two-year contracts so
that will control the transfer portal
but I also think next four years we're
gonna have four conferences the NCAA
tournaments can be those four
conferences the one bid leagues are all
going to go into one poll they're going
to play each other to play into the NCAA
tournament so more teams from those four
conferences that might have 20 or 25
teams in them uh will be in the
tournament because basically that's
where the money is being generated but
uh yeah it's something it's another
thing you got to manage you know I saw
Jay the other night at dinner it was
funny uh I asked Patty I said you
enjoying retirement because that's what
my wife calls what I do now retirement
you know because the season's over and
uh she she turned to Karen and my wife
she's we are loving it yeah so you know
it look the business has changed it's
always been a business but we never got
it guys my generation never got into it
for money it became money but like you
just wanted a team to coach my first job
was 12-5 I mean I was happy as a lark
you know I thought I was a millionaire
you know my first job at head coaching
job was sixty thousand dollars I thought
it was a millionaire I never had an
agent for coaching I was an idiot
you know it's uh hey you get a team to
coach that's what you always wanted to
do you live in your dream you know you
didn't think now it's a business
back up point guards in college
basketball making more than that
oh goodness gracious I mean I think a
lot of schools are doing what I call
across the board so they have either
collectors where everyone makes the same
amount
I mean 200 300 000 I mean if you put
your dad I just want to let you know if
you put your name in the portal and
became a free agent
all right you could make a lot of a lot
of money and then I'll tell you the
other thing is now you've got these new
we used to call them Runners that would
like get them college campuses develop
relationships with players then hand
them off to the agent
now the runners are agents but what
they're doing is you had a pretty good
season I come to say damn you know you
had a pretty good season you know
it's great that you're at school X Y and
Z but I tell you I just talked to these
guys over here they really like you the
starting figure is X well but wait a
second but I really like where I'm at
I'm playing for Coach I'm I like my role
I like my teammates whoa you're not
listening now Dan I'm telling you this
school here
well yeah that sounds great because that
agent's gonna get 20 percent
of the deal number one so do they have
unconditional love and number two is
like as as a player you've got to
understand it's like an NBA trade you
always know what you're getting rid of
you never know what you get
but it is also a business
yeah I mean he's gonna be he's gonna
make some money on the open market here
oh man he's gonna some money
that dude's that's that is if Nigel
packs worth 400 000 a year for two years
basically eight hundreds of thousand
dollars an apartment in a car
okay no names best recruiting story that
you ever heard about what somebody got
the best recruiting story uh
League you mean back in the day whenever
yeah whatever somebody got look back
look back in the day what it came down
to there was honor amongst these right I
mean that's just the way it is uh
I could just tell you my funniest
recruiting story is I'm recording this
is personal and it's it's not about a
lot but I walk into a gym in Georgia and
when Sanderson is there and and sunny
Smith is there and I was working for
Bill Foster at Miami we're just starting
a program that and I sit down and I sit
with Coach Sanderson and and uh and
Coach Smith and they turned to me in
legitimately straight faced and said
Seth I know Bill don't cheat and my
opening number is 50 which was 50 000.
that was like in in 84.85 and I know
Sonny's going to go to 100. so what the
hell are you doing here
and and I mean like back in the and I I
remember that was before so I I I got I
got it back to the hotel I called coach
Foster and he the first question he
asked was well who was there
and I said Sonny and whip he goes well
that was a waste of time
oh
oh that was so funny he he I said coach
I thought we he goes we're done it's
like a card game we got to know where to
hold them when to fold them
next next Prospect
great to talk to you and uh thanks for
joining us as always all right thank you
appreciate you man that's uh Seth
Greenberg former college coach uh ESPN
college basketball analyst we'll take a
break at our play of the day coming up